de chef de l'opposition.
Christian Noël.eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee
estivale, les députés rapportent
O Ottawa les préoccupations
économiques de leurs électeurs.
RICHARD MARTEL, député, Parti
- Il reste que le monde
a de la difficulté pareil
à mettre du manger sur la table,
puis de payer leur gaz, là.
ALsesesesesesesesesesesesesesesc
- "J'ai de la misère à payer
l'épicerie. Le prix de la
viande, des légumes, des fruits,
c'est de plus en p
ministre du Patrimoine canadien
- "Est-ce que  s suis capable
de nourrir mes enfants? Est-ce
que je suis capable d'acheter
des médicatututututututututututi
trouvent écho aux Communes.
(applaisissements)
Des munitions pour le nouveau
chef de l'opposition officielle
po f f f f f f f f f f f f f f .
PIERRE POILIEVRE, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Canada
- Les Canadiens ne peuvent
plus payer. Est-ce que
ses augmentations de taxes sur
les aînés et les travailleurs?
- Pas de duel avec Justin
Trudeau, qui est en voyage à
l'ONU.
qui vient de ses ministres.
RANDY BOISSONNAULT, ministre
fédéral associé des Finances
- Argent dans les poches
des Canadiils en ont besoin.
- Pour marquer la rentrée,
les libéraux déposent
finalement leur plan de
lutt
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS,
ministre fédéral de la Santé
- Tout le monde ressent durement
l'effet de l'augmentation
du coût de la vie. m m m m m m t
de TPS doublé : jusqu'à 460 $
de plus pour un couple
avec deux enfants.
- Un soutien s e e e e e e e e s
de personnes.
- Pour ceux qui peinent à payer
le loyer : paiement unique
de 500
à faible revenu : jusqu'à
650 $ par enfant par année
pour les soins dentaires.
- On estime que le programme
500 000 enfants canadiens.
- Coût total des nouvelles
mesures : 4,5 milliards
de dollars.épépépépépépépépépépC
Charlesbourg-Haute-St-Charles Qc
- Donner de l'argent, c'est
une chose, mais il y a des taxes
qui sont chargées deDoDoDoDoDoDs
la situation de personne.
- "Est-ce qu'il va falloir que
je revienne à ce qui se passait
dans le tempe e e e e e e e e er
aller arracher la dent de mon
fils?" Moi, c'est ce que j'ai
entendu chez nous, puis c'est
pas
On veut aider les Canadiens
les plus vulnérables. Et ceux
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
ça, je vous dirais que c'est
- Bref, le ton monte d'un cran.
À preuve lala nouvelle
publicité du NPD qui
attaque Pierre Poilievre.
"Je suis le défenseur des
famieses et des travailleurs."
Mais si on regarde le bilan
de
systématiquement, il s'est rangé
dudu côté des grandes compagnie,
des pétrolières.
- De leur côetetetetetetetetete,
de rester courtois.
MARK HOLLAND, leader du gouv.
à la Chambre des communes
- Je s
de façon raisonnable
avec ton respectueux.
- L'inflation semble ralentir.
Elle a connu un deuxième recul
mais la pression demeure sur
le portefeuille des Canadiens.
Pierre Poilievre, lui, veut
porter ce flambeau aux Communes.
avec Justin Trudeau sur
la question est attendu ududi.
Ici Christian Noël,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw